une journée cruciale à temps les parents
de sophie lyonnais ce lundi à londres
wissem mediouni et sabrina kouider les
meurtriers présumés de leurs filles vont
devoir s'expliquer devant la cour
criminelle du old bailey
ils clament toujours leur innocence
pourtant les faits présentés pendant les
quatre premières semaines de procès
semble qu'accablant sophie lyonnais dont
le cadavre a été retrouvé carbonisé dans
le jardin du couple
le 20 septembre 2010 est aurait subi un
calvaire selon l'accusation
pendant vingt mois cette jeune fille au
pair a été affamé frappé et torturé
elle a également subi des
interrogatoires de plusieurs heures pour
lui faire avouer un complot son
employeuse
sabrina kouider était persuadé que la
jeune femme voulait droguer et agressé
sexuellement les membres de sa famille
avec la complicité de son ancien
compagnon le chanteur mark walton
fondateur du boys band boyzone
ce dernier affirme n'avoir jamais
rencontré la jeune icaunaise d'après
l'autopsié le décès de sophie lyonnais a
pu être causée par noyade dans la
baignoire du couple par une chute ou
sous les coups selon le procureur il est
le résultat final d'une violences
intentionnelles et continue les accusés
essaierons de le convaincre qu'ils ont
seulement tenté de se débarrasser du
corps
le procès doit durer jusqu'au 11 mai